happy nutrition Dawn's this month's
theme is all about eating well from nine
to five so today I'm zoning in on
commuter cravings so if you rush out the
door no breakfast or you're coming home
and you're re starve you probably bored
tired and getting a little bit hangry
stop don't go to that drive through and
get that doughnut that's gonna spike
your blood sugar crash you down and
leave you're meeting another quick fix
in an hour
prep yourself we find three top commuter
friendly snacks they're gonna keep you
satiated and stabilize your blood sugar
so you arrive at your destination hangry
road rage free my first go-to is apple
with almond butter I slice a half an
apple into wedges spritz it with a
little bit of lemon juice to prevent
browning and smear with a tablespoon of
almond butter and a sprinkle of cinnamon
I look for snacks that are low on the
glycemic index meaning they release fuel
gradually to prevent insulin spikes
which in turn can help you manage your
weight and hunger this effect is even
greater in combination with a little
fiber protein get healthy fat you also
want to make sure your snacks are easy
to eat mess free and odorless for you
public transit takers next up is my
chili spice chickpeas this is a great
snack for prepping the night before I
toast 1/2 a cup of canned chickpeas in a
hot skillet with a teaspoon of olive oil
and a sprinkle of sea salt chili powder
and cumin
then I put them in the oven under the
broiler until they get nice and crispy
cool them down and then transfer them to
a small Tupperware container and finally
for those days I just don't have time to
pack myself something I always keep some
solar energy bears on hand and I rarely
recommend energy bars because some of
them are just slow to the sugar they're
pretty much just glorified candy bars
but I like these solar bars because
they've got protein fiber and are
certified as the first low GI bar on the
market so you'll have the energy to get
through your commute and maybe you'll
even get to the gym I managed to find a
bunch of these great flavors at the
grocery store pharmacy health food store
and trust me they all taste just as good
as that sugary candy bar so before you
leave for work makes your prepped with
all my three top commuter friendly
snacks that'll help you travel healthier
happier and hangry free thanks so much
for watching be sure to subscribe to my
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen take a peek at my top 3
power snack they'll help boost you out
of that free PM energy slump
you